don't hurt yourself that's it whether
it's building counting sharing the early
years are critical when it comes to
setting children up for the next steps
at school and Beyond
but with living costs Rising nurseries
like this one find parents are cutting
back their hours with children only
coming in when they're eligible for
government funding at age three it's
quite so destroying because I think we
do such a good job here they seem to
wait until they can until it's funded
and that's had a huge impact I did
recently increase my fees varies a very
small amount but it doesn't reflect that
the fact there's only two children or
three children that are actually only
just doing two sessions a week so what
impact has all this had on your finances
I've had to put money in I've had to
reduce staff costs and all the staff had
to drop a session I do everything for
this nurse always have I'm very
passionate about it but I have to be
realistic that if if I can't make ends
meet I will have to close
three and four-year-old children do get
government funding for some of their
child care but nurseries warn it's a
double-edged sword because the money
they get doesn't cover all the costs so
they're left struggling what's this one
what color have we got here working
parents say what they want is more
support at an earlier stage I think
would have been the sort of earlier
funding from the age of maybe two two
and a half you know that did impact on
our finances back then and we could only
put our children in for a few hours a
week I would have been able to work
maybe a day or two more
ads um have the funding been there as
well when he was a bit younger providers
expect to raise fees by eight percent on
average this year a thousand pounds for
children under three in full-time care
more than half said they had operated at
a loss last year and thousands have
already closed their doors
the government is looking at Solutions
and Tory MPS are pushing for an
announcement in the March budget there
are things about the existing system
which aren't working as well as they
should so for instance The Upfront
payments and Universal Credit and
tax-free child care which are putting a
lot of parents off using them at all
that is there is money there designed to
be going in subsidy which is currently
not coming into the system labor say the
whole system needs an overhaul we know
that cost pressures for parents are
increasing all of the time and that you
know it's harder than ever to find a
child care place that has to change and
that's why Labor's plans will deliver a
modern child care system from the end of
Parental leave right through to the end
of primary school
the government say they recognize the
pressures that families and providers
are under but they'll have to decide
which children get a helping hand
tomorrow Cohen Sky News Hertfordshire